[Music]
Harlem doesn't meet a hero it means a
queen this isn't Luke obviously he's
Harlem's hero but the ladies are also
having a new sense of confidence where
are we gonna be in season two how are
things gonna shake up this season I
think the ladies have always been
confident but the the cameras put us in
the center of the frame more this year
and we dominate that position as we
always do you don't need to be
bulletproof to be a superhero black
women have always had superpowers I
think not only just on mothers tots or
up at Hallows paradise but even in the
precinct and it is not uncommon in life
that that the women are in charge I
think men are the face of power and
brawn but but the real the weight
lifting goes on and and women do all of
that work that's the women's work yeah
and I what I love specifically with my
character me because there's definitely
the obvious where like you know Mariah
and with misty there's a strength and
there's a power that is undeniable it's
unmistakable and then there's women like
Tilda who sometimes there's a quiet
strength about them and then sometimes
they have to make themselves to be a
little louder for you to recognize the
strengths and things that they do bring
to the table I think watching the
journey have told us something pretty
interesting for the fans I can't wait
and she's recovering now how has she
navigated that role one thing that I
noticed about her I think it was very
frustrating for misty because she know
it's a person used to being able to
fight our way out of anything and when
suddenly when you when that is amputated
you have to find a new strength and she
really I know that's a little
heartbreaking although I'd like to kick
her but but but to watch her find her to
find her power again to find her inner
inner strength and so when she comes
back she comes back strong
position on my sidekick me it's my show
[Music]